[Musique]
malgré toutes les révélations sur des
curés des religieux pédophiles
pouvez-vous croire qu'il y a encore un
diocèse qui protège certains d'entre eux
[Musique]
juste pour être clair ce que vous nous
dites c'est que vous avez jamais fait
d'attouchement sexuel sur un mineur
[Musique]
donc c'était soit les abus sexuels soit
la prison
le nouvel évêque de hearth dans le Nord
de l'Ontario a appris par notre
journaliste que son mandat ne serait pas
tout repos alors si elle est prête qui
devait être retirées du ministère ce
sera fait ce sera fait
pour raconter cette histoire nous avons
roulé 11 heures à partir de Toronto vers
une région où l'Église a protégé des
abuseurs sexuels à légué et même
condamné leur victime veulent que ça
sert
moi je veux être
excommunié vous voulez connaître en fait
au fil ça
dans un seul diocèse
d'autres et bénévoles ont été
montrés
à 14 ans puis je le connaissais pas
nécessairement 14 ans notre enquête a
recensé pas moins d'une quarantaine de
personnes qui auraient subi des abus
sexuels de la fin des années 1950 au
début des années 2010
[Musique]
le diocèse de Heuss occupe un vaste
territoire majoritairement francophone
dans le Nord de l'Ontario la religion
catholique a encore des racines
profondes ici ces parois sont été
fondées au siècle dernier par des
prêtres venus du Québec
jouait un grand rôle dans la
conscientisation des francophones et
occupe toujours une place importante
dans la vie sociale
l'Église a assuré son influence grâce à
l'isolement géographique et linguistique
de la population
c'est ce qui aurait permis à l'église de
camoufler des abus ici plus longtemps
qu'ailleurs
la population elle vivait du bois c'est
toujours le cas aujourd'hui
la forêt pour moi c'est
un lieu de
où je peux me ressourcer
mais c'est aussi un lieu où ce que je
peux
faire le vide on a tous besoin de petits
îlots de tranquillité
quand on était adolescent on se pose des
questions
et puis une des questions que je me
posais aussi c'était est-ce que je t'ai
appelé aller vers la Prêterie
il va rencontrer le curé Rémi Lessard à
l'âge de 17 ans en 1985 un prêtre
nouveau genre très populaire auprès des
jeunes les personnes du clergé étaient
vus comme des vedettes il paraissait
personne de confiance il a commencé à te
donner beaucoup d'attention après ça
par la suite ma mère
a eu des problèmes de santé
éventuellement apporter un décès
il nous confix son père était absent et
que le curé les sort l'accueilli chez
lui
ça me réconfortait donc c'était une
figure paternelle pour toi oui oui
je pourrais être ton père
l'année suivante se rappelle-t-il le
curé lui donne des accolades et des
baisers qui culminent à un moment
troublant
il me dit j'aimerais que tu couches avec
moi
ivresis puis propose un compromis ici
une ligne imaginaire qui est le milieu
du lit puis que je te vois pas la
dépasser ça peut être long que
excusez le mais son petit pénis de 2
pouces me frôler le derrière de la jambe
pour savoir que
j'étais comme
pris par otage
[Musique]
le jeune le repousse il s'enfuit le
curry ne recommence pas mais
l'interaction le laisse profondément
traumatisée
c'est à ce moment là que j'ai perdu
toute confiance
pour longtemps
[Musique]
quand tu es coiffeur
est un peu psychologue peut-être un peu
gynécologue et
des affaires qu'un homme qui devait pas
savoir que mes coiffeurs
c'était juste comme
cette thérapie pour moi
[Musique]
la coiffure m'a sauvé
les malheurs de Gilles commencent à
l'enfant
je m'appelle de là
arrête d'agir comme une [__]
de faire [__]
il est aussi abusé et sexuellement par
son père
quelque chose je me suis réveillé avec
quelque chose de dur mais il fait
[Musique]
l'église a été un refuge pour Gilles en
particulier les activités jeunesse où il
rencontre Roger prenovo à l'âge de 14
ans
je sais pas
[Musique]
me montrer de la fiction que je vais que
j'aurais aimé qu'on parle me donne
[Musique]
mais pas maintenant
est-ce que toute la terre qui m'accès
c'était les doigts glissaient en dessous
les bobettes
j'ai le soutien que l'abus a duré des
années il n'était pas le seul jeune dans
leur [__] de Roger prenovo arc-en-ciel
c'est une communauté de vie où on recrée
un monde différent pour les jeunes qui
ont eu des problèmes avec la drogue
l'alcool dans les années 80 le diocèse
dirigeait un centre de désintoxication
sur une ferme pour les 12 à 24 ans la
Maison Arc-en-Ciel
c'est entre autres à Roger prenovo et
Rémi Lessard que l'Église confie ses
jeunes vulnérables qui arrivait du
système de justice
faut vraiment que les gens sortent d'ici
de façon épanouie les prêtres dormaient
sur place ils étaient aussi agents de
probation tout était en place pour ce
qui nous a été décrit comme une maison
des horreurs Joël rivet arrive en 1981 à
l'âge de 16 ans après avoir été arrêté
pour des vols le juge lui donne deux
choix la prison ou la Maison Arc-en-Ciel
en prison ça va pas se taquois j'avais
peur j'ai décidé que oui peut-être la
princesse ça sera mieux de banqueries
c'est un autre prêtre le curé René
Poirier qu'il prend en charge mais au
lieu de le réhabiliter il en fait sa
proie c'est un peu embarrassant
[Musique]
mais je voulais pas partir parce que si
je partais en prison donc c'était soit
les abus sexuels soit la prison
deux autres ex résidents nous confient
avoir subi des agressions sexuelles de
René Poirier
mais aussi d'un bénévole Ghislain
[Musique]
plourdements dans la dans la douche
un camp de vacances c'est la grande
force du cœur c'est tout ça tourne
autour du mot amour une présence
amoureuse une présence aimante il a
refusé notre demande d'entrevue son nom
reviendra plus tard dans cette histoire
pour ce qui est de René Poirier il est
enfin dénoncé à l'évêque par un autre
jeune en 1982 mais au lieu de le punir
l'église ferme les yeux les vagues Roger
des parties le transfert à Chapelot mais
dans sa nouvelle paroisse le curé
Poirier continue de travailler comme
thérapeute en 1989 il agresse un autre
adolescent
au retour on a confronté un prêtre visé
par des allégations d'agression
sexuelles c'est rare qu'une personne
dans ce contexte accepte de nous donner
une entrevue mais vous allez voir que
c'est troublant
[Musique]
puis je le connaissais pas 14 ans
ce qui est encore plus choquant pour les
victimes qui témoignent maintenant c'est
que ce scandale était tout fait par le
diocèse de Heart depuis longtemps et que
l'impunité règne regardez ce qui est
arrivé à ce curé condamné il y a 30 ans
au début des années 90 le diocèse est
plongé dans un scandale le curé René
Poirier et Coop de 6 mois de prison pour
l'agression sexuelle d'un adolescent de
17 ans
et l'évêque Roger des Pâtis et poursuivi
au civils pour avoir camouflé l'affaire
se transfère silencieux comme je
l'appelle les deux modèles appliqué dans
le bon catholique le prêtre est absous
de ces péchés en thérapie ou dans une
retraite spirituelle puis transféré dans
une autre paroi
en 1994 les vagues des Pâtis est
condamné pour négligence grave il dit à
16 paye 43 500 dollars c'était près de
10 ans avant l'avalanche de litiges qui
allait déferler mondialement contre
l'Église à l'aube des années 2000 selon
des critiques de l'institution ce
jugement a été une occasion ratée
c'est un recours très rarement utilisé
par les tribunaux et qu'il ait été
utilisé contre un diocèse catholique en
Ontario aurait dû être créé sur tous les
toits cela aurait dû être un moment pour
l'église de modifier ses comportements
de transfert silencieux et de rompre le
silence
au contraire le diocèse a continué de
protéger des abuseurs dans le curé
Poirier
à sa sortie de prison l'église transfère
encore le prêtre cette fois aux
Philippines il meurt au Mexique en 2006
ce genre de camouflage est quelque chose
que Rob talac voit souvent de
Ottawa à London en passant par Mountain
dans ses boîtes se trouvent certains des
pires secrets des diocèses du pays ce
qui lui a valu le surnom de chasseur de
prêtres dans le milieu
le titre de chasseur de prêtres est un
honneur car c'est prêtres ont mérité
d'être chassés je me concentre sur ceux
qui ont commis des incendies de sexuels
sur des enfants ou exploiter des
personnes vulnérables
l'un des prêtres que le diocèse de Heuss
a protégé jusqu'à très récemment et
Roger prenovo il a travaillé pendant des
décennies après les abus qui leurraient
fait subir agile
prenovo est aujourd'hui à la retraite
nous l'avons retracé et convaincu de
nous accorder une entrevue
[Musique]
est-ce que le nom de Gilles Gina vous
dit quelque chose
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez eu des rapports
sexuels avec Gilles parce que je sache
mais quelques minutes plus tard il n'a
plus de trous de mémoire il se rappelle
même de plusieurs détails spécifiques
moi je me rappelle de lui quand il
travaillait déjà dans un restaurant puis
de me reprocher ses parents ses
souvenirs en denti nous surprennent
parce que Roger prenovo a revu Gilles il
n'y a pas si longtemps
c'était en 2014 qu'il décidait de le
confronter en personne
Roger quand je l'ai confronté
à 14 ans
je le connaissais pas 14 ans
jamais pris responsabilité ça je
n'en connais pas
les relations sexuelles à légué
n'étaient pas un acte criminel à
l'époque la loi allait changer seulement
quelques années plus tard mais est-ce
que cela veut dire qu'elles étaient
appropriées pour autant
ok disons qu'il avait 16 ans est-ce que
ça aurait été approprié d'avoir des
relations sexuelles avec lui à sa maison
je pense que c'est un débats
donc je vois pas où vous voulez en venir
selon Gilles la confrontation a menée à
des révélations bouleversantes Roger
prenovo lui aurait admis que d'autres
jeunes lui ont reproché des abus
similaires
le soir
je vois pas pourquoi tu es prêt en effet
prenons vous aurait fait des ravages au
long de sa carrière en quête à
identifier quatre autres personnes qui
auraient subi des abus sexuels de sa
part alors qu'elles étaient mineurs
juste pour être clair ce que vous nous
dites c'est que vous avez jamais fait
d'attouchement sexuel sur un mineur
[Musique]
a mené à une accusation d'agression
sexuelle sur un adolescent en 2014
prenovo appelé des coupables deux ans
plus tard à une accusation réduite de
voies de fait sur un mineur
[Musique]
si Roger prenovo pouvait vous entendre
que vous voudriez vous lui dire
vous voulez connaître un pédophile ça
ça
c'est un privilège
de vivre librement dans ton corps
[Musique]
moi je savais que
ça n'emmènerait à rien de garder le
silence c'est comme si en moi il y avait
cette rage que je portais parce que on a
voulu prendre davantage de moi durant
les années 90 et 2000 Yves dit avoir
tenté à plusieurs reprises de dénoncer
Rémi Lessard la couronne refuse de
porter des accusations il s'adresse aux
diocèse mais rien n'est fait et il
traverse une période noire
[Musique]
briser la propriété d'autrui oui
en 2010 il tente une nouvelle stratégie
enregistrée Rémi Lessard et les vagues
Vincent Cadieu à leur insu
de façon à faire le trouble j'ai fait ça
pour me faire respecter j'ai fait ça
pour qu'on entende la vérité
[Musique]
pour qu'un individu
de ta personne
de ton savoir de ton statut de ton
pouvoir peut faire ça
plus démunis que j'étais dans le
temps se dirigeable c'est
ce que j'ai pas de réponse ça c'est
le fait de d'avoir pas mal
d'avoir comme
ce sujet du possiblement d'avoir des
rapports sexuels
j'ai abandonné tous les activités avec
les jeunes
malgré cette confession les vagues
Cadieux se portent à sa défense
[Musique]
urs
décide de poursuivre et pour ce faire il
embauche robe talac
j'ai accepté son cas parce que j'ai cru
à son histoire même s'il était plus
vieux et que le CV ça a été bref ça
reste très significatif il y avait aussi
que dans son cas l'abuseur semble être
sans remord
en effet Rémi Lessard ni les allégations
et va jusqu’à suggérer que Yves le
harcèle il dit à 16 rejettes toute
responsabilité mais un élément preuve va
tout changer alors
le document la preuve l'enregistrement
a été le
a été le moment ils ont qui a fait
déclencher le tout
son enregistrement audio nous serions
encore en litige en 2017 Yves Villeneuve
reçoit 75000 dollars dans un règlement à
l'amiable mais il y a 16 ans
a décliné notre demande d'entrevue
de plusieurs prêtres aujourd'hui décédés
à coup de centaines de milliers de
dollars
en secret l'église voulait absolument
cesser l'hémorragie
[Musique]
après la pause notre équipe va aller à
la rencontre du nouvel évêque de Heart
qui va prendre la mesure du scandale
qu'il aura géré
est-ce que ça veut dire qu'il y a
potentiellement des archives qui
manquent
[Musique]
la question s'est posée dans plusieurs
scandales sexuels qui ont éclaboussé
l'Église catholique où est l'argent pour
compenser les victimes le diocèse de
Hearts a conçu un stratagème financier
pour se protéger des poursuites
[Musique]
depuis plusieurs années l'Église
catholique vient un séisme sans
précédent Alban Irlande États-Unis les
affaires de pédophilie ne cessent de se
succéder au sein de l'Église catholique
nous avons des nombreux environ 216
000 victimes
de Paris à Santa Fe dédiocèses ont
transféré de l'argent et des biens
immobiliers dans des corporations
distinctes selon plusieurs grands médias
pour les cacher de poursuites de
victimes d'abus sexuels la stratégie
existe au Canada le Diaz de Charles Town
reconnaissait la voix employée en 2011
et selon des avocats qui ont poursuivi
l'église le diocèse de Halifax a tenté
de le faire après sa fusion avec celui
du Hermès en 2017
c'est restructuration sont une faillite
morale l'église marchande le peu de
crédibilité qui lui reste pour économ
omiser quelques dollars
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de Heuss entamait sa propre
restructuration une fusion avec celui de
moussoni au Nord selon des documents
internes du diocèse obtenu par enquête
l'évêque Robert Bourgon proposait
de créer une nouvelle corporation avec
tous les avoir disponibles des paroisses
les soustrayant ainsi à des poursuites
légales
des avoir nettes de plus de 30 millions
de dollars selon nos calculs les prêtres
approuvent le plan à l'unanimité mais
avant qu'il soit complété les vagues
bourgons démissionnent en 2020 la
restructuration est mise sur la glace
jusqu'à la nomination d'un nouvel évêque
un an et demi plus tard le pape François
choisit Monseigneur Pierre-Olivier
Tremblay pour le remplacer est-ce que
vous êtes au courant de cette stratégie
ça n'existe pas donc c'est possible que
lui avait cette idée de le faire mais ça
ne s'est pas fait avez-vous déjà vu
cette ce schéma là
non
lui avons montré une copie du plan de
restructuration qui prévoyait la
création d'une série de corporations
distinctes il maintient de société
coquilles pour brouiller les pistes
la corporation
qui semblait avoir été envisagé n'existe
pas on est encore avec les corporations
telles qu'elles étaient il n'est pas
question de faire des
démarches pour protéger quoi que ce soit
de notre de notre justice par exemple
je pense que le diocèse a été pris en
flagrant délire en créant une structure
pour se protéger des litiges et de ses
responsabilités
le diocèse devrait proclamer
publiquement que les victimes seront
toujours indemnisées peu importe sa
structure organisationnelle
contrairement à d'autres victimes Gilles
n'a pas eu la force de poursuivre mais
il a quand même parlé avec quelqu'un au
diocèse en 2014 pour dénoncer Roger
prenovo j'ai juste une confirmation
je vais faire quelque chose
si tu as besoin de parler appelle-moi
je vais t'écouter c'est tout
Gilles n'a jamais eu de retour de
l'évêque et malgré sa condamnation pour
voie de fait sur un mineur en 2016 Roger
prenovo a continué d'être curé pendant
trois ans
plus inquiétant encore nous révélons à
l'évêque trembler que deux autres
prêtres toujours en fonction sont visées
par des allégations d'agressions
sexuelles et quand ces employés a fait
de la prison pour avoir agressé
sexuellement des enfants
chaque personne c'est une vie qui qui
brisée qui a affecté chaque cas et est
une tragédie puis on va se rencontrer et
on va prendre des mesures qui devront
être prises alors si elle est prête qui
devait être retirées du ministère ce
sera fait ça sera fait
mais il était un an qu'il ne soit pas au
courant d'un autre cas celui de Ghislain
Claude nous avons constaté que 40 ans
après les sévices commis à la Maison
Arc-en-Ciel il demeure bénévoles pour
l'église du mieux que je peux pour nous
aider à prier
aujourd'hui nous allons entendre encore
parler beaucoup de la foi
et ce même s'il a été accusé d'agression
sexuelle en 2020 et l'année suivante
plaidait coupable à des accusations
réduites de voies de fait sur un mineur
et même après ce qu'il aurait fait vivre
à Joël
riveté
vous au courant mais est-ce que ça vous
inquiète pas bien sûr mais on doit tout
prendre les mesures nécessaires pour que
tout le monde se sente en sécurité ça
c'est très important
finalement il nous a dit ne rien savoir
à propos de presque toutes les
allégations que nous lui avons présenté
sauf un autre cas il savait que son curé
Rémi Lessard avait été accusé d'un
conduites sexuelle dans une cause aussi
vide
alors
inutile de nous culpabiliser de nous
culpabiliser le Seigneur regarde pas les
fautes ce que j'ai à comprendre c'est
qu'il y a eu un cas et qui a été réglé à
l'amiable mais c'est ça les informations
que j'en ai mais il y a 16 avaient reçu
à l'époque la confession de Rémi Lessard
avoir comme
ce sujet possiblement d'avoir des
rapports sexuels ça c'est fait
inacceptable
ce que j'entends c'est la première fois
j'entends ça OK et je ne peux pas me
prononcer sur l'ensemble de la
conversation et l'ensemble des des
interaction qu'il a eu lieu les vagues
se défend il vient d'arriver c'est
pourquoi il n'est pas au fait des cas et
poursuites passé mais selon ses propres
règles l'Église doit conserver des
archives sur toutes les allégations et
mises à l'endroit de son clergé c'est
pourquoi la réponse de Monseigneur
tremblait nous inquiète
si nous avons des victimes qui nous
disent avoir fait des dénonciations
à vos prédécesseurs et que là vous me
dites que vous n'avez pas trouvé
d'historique de ces dénonciations là
dans les archives est-ce que ça veut
dire qu'il y a potentiellement des
archives qui manquent
[Musique]
les vagues devrait être effrayés que
quelque chose lui échappe qu'il y ait
des agresseurs dans ses reins ce serait
un immense scandale un gâchis si
quelqu'un savait quelque chose et n'a
pas pris les actions nécessaires
il devrait vérifier qui sont ces hommes
qui l'entourent ce n'est pas une grosse
organisation moi j'ai aimé toute
personne qui ont vécu des abus à
dénoncer à bien nous rencontrer ou aller
voir la police et à partir de
dénonciation on va agir on va agir de
nous voir
suite à notre entrevue les vagues
tremblaient à lancer une enquête interne
tous les prêtres et bénévoles mentionnés
dans ce reportage ont été relevés de
leur fonction incluant Rémi Lessard
[Musique]
pour Gilles qui a dénoncé Roger prenovo
au diocèse sans succès en 2014 c'est
trop peu trop tard qui a se faire [__]
sa région
protéger des pétophiles si longtemps
je serai plus
à la région catholique après ce que j'ai
vu là peut-être ça comme moi c'est une
histoire toute la patente de l'histoire
un peu eux ils ont qu'un prophètent vous
avez besoin d'aide
pour mes beaux yeux
de la misère en vie puis
ça a vraiment un peu le rocher depuis ce
temps là
[Musique]